Tatort Deutschland präsentiert den
dunklen Januar jeden Tag ein neuer
Kriminalfall ein tägliches Tatort
Deutschlands Spezial mein Name ist
skadymo und ich wünsche euch eine
spannende Krimizeit
und mein Name ist Natalie Strauß ich bin
Radiomoderatorin und habe darum im
Alltagsgeschäft eher mit der Gegenwart
und dem Polizeibericht von letzter Nacht
zu tun hier schauen wir aber in die
Vergangenheit und nehmen uns
Kriminalfälle vor die uns aus dem ein
oder anderen Grund immer noch
beschäftigen heute holen wir einen Fall
raus der nicht nur einer der
bekanntesten sondern auch einer der
mysteriösesten Kriminalfälle ist und bis
heute ungelöst es geht um einen Mord
vielleicht sogar ein Doppelmord
die Geschichte beginnt jedoch nicht
damit dass eine Leiche auftaucht alles
beginnt fünf Jahre vor der Tat und statt
eines toten taucht ein eindeutig
lebendiger wenn auch sehr seltsamer
junger Mann auf keiner kann uns besser
in die spannende Welt des True Crime
entführen als Sprecher und Moderator
Mirko Kasimir Mirko leg los hallo grüß
Dich Natalie freue mich dich zu sehen
und liebe Grüße auch in unsere Podcast
Hörerinnen und Hörer schön dass ihr
dabei seid heute reden wir über einen
der bekanntesten Kriminalfälle überhaupt
ich glaube das kann man ohne
Übertreibung sagen zu seiner Zeit war er
nämlich das Gespräch nicht nur in
Deutschland sondern in ganz Europa
dieser Fall ist die Inspiration für
zahllose Romane Theaterstücke Filme
Gedichte und Lieder und immer wieder
wird darauf Bezug genommen und er hat
sogar Eingang in psychologische
Wörterbücher gefunden das Mysterium
fängt aber schon damit an dass nicht
einmal sicher ist dass es sich überhaupt
um mordet
na sagen wir so es ist umstritten denn
beide Opfer beharten darauf dass sie
ermordet wurden nein nein keine Angst
wir sind nicht total abgedriftet und
erzählen jetzt irgendeine Story mit
Geistern und Zions in denen Opfer aus
dem Jenseits jetzt noch mal ihre Mörder
verraten aber es ist doch so Krimis
beginnen normalerweise damit dass eine
Leiche gefunden wird in der Realität
überleben die Opfer aber häufig und er
liegen erst später ihren Verletzungen
und vorher können Sie manchmal noch eine
Aussage machen sowas auch hier der Fall
beginnt also nicht damit dass eine
Leiche auftaucht es beginnt fünf Jahre
vor der Tat und statt einer Leiche
taucht ein eindeutig lebendiger wer noch
sehr seltsamer junger Mann auf
Nürnberg 26 mai 1828
schumachermeister Weickmann hat den
jungen Mann der mit ungelenkten
Schritten über den unschnitt Platz wankt
noch nie gesehen der Junge ruft etwas
Unverständliches und bewegt sich als
müsse er bei jedem Schritt das Laufen
neu erfinden steif und ruckartig und den
ausgestreckten Armen hält er zwei Briefe
Weidmann ist ein hilfsbereiter Mann
niemand den die offensichtliche not
eines Fremden kalt lässt und so geht er
dem Jungen entgegen fragt die nach
Befinden und Begehr und erhält statt
einer Antwort eine Adresse neue
Torstraße ist das das Ziel des jungen
einer der beiden Briefe ist an den
Rittmeister der vierten Eskadron des
sechsten chefaloge Regiments in Nürnberg
adressiert
Weidmann weist ihm den Weg zur Wohnung
des Weltmeisters dort angekommen spricht
der Junge den ersten langen
verständlichen Satz
ein solcher Reiter möchte ich werden wie
mein Vater gewesen ist
das klang jetzt ganz schön Hochdeutsch
aber der Junge spricht mit starken
altbayerischen Dialekt das ist sehr
ungewöhnlich im fränkischen Nürnberg und
er spricht genauso unbeholfen wie er
läuft offenbar ist seine Zunge im
sprechen so wenig geübt wie seine Beine
im laufen ja das muss schon eine
ziemlich seltsame Situation gewesen sein
nach einem kurzen Aufenthalt im Haus des
friedmeisters wird der junge Mann zur
Polizeiwache geführt die Fragen die ihm
gestellt werden scheint er nicht zu
verstehen man hält ihn für einen
hoffnungslos zurückgebliebenen dann
liegt jemand Papier und Feder vor ihn
auf den Tisch der Junge greift die
federt sie in ein Tintenfass und dann
schreibt er langsam und angestrengt aber
deutlich lesbar zwei Worte er schreibt
seine Namen Kasper Hauser der erste der
beiden Briefe der bei sich hat stammt
angeblich von einem Tagelöhner von der
bayerischen Grenze
Kaspar Hauser sei ein Findelkind dass er
aufgenommen aufgezogen und im
Christentum unterrichtet habe aber nie
für die Tür gelassen hat nun weil er
Reiter werden der zweite Brief ist
angeblich von der Mutter des Kindes der
Vater ist ein chevalon vom sechsten
Regiment der aber tot sei das
Geburtsdatum ist wohl der
30.04.1812 der Junge ist also nun 16
Jahre alt der Wahrheitsgehalt ist sehr
umstritten der angebliche Brief der
Mutter wirkt als sei er von derselben
Person allerdings mit verstellter
Handschrift geschrieben worden aber
wohin nun mit dem jungen Mann bringt ihn
zunächst im Gefängnis unter das ist ja
damals normal gewesen also so ist man
einfach mit Findelkindern zum Teil
umgegangen aber klar es gab zu der Zeit
einfach gar kein Jugendamt früher war
auch nicht alles besser anfangs nimmt
Kaspar Hauser nichts als Wasser und Brot
zu sich obwohl man durchaus versucht ihn
gut zu verköstigen doch es scheint so
als könne er mit allen anderen Speisen
nichts anfangen
das habe er bis zu diesem Tag nichts
anderes als Wasser und Brot
kennengelernt später beschreibt Hauser
sein Leben so man habe ihn in
halbliegender Stellung in einem
fastlichtlosen Raum festgehalten wenn er
schlief habe man ihn gewaschen seine
Kleidung gewechselt ihm Wasser und Brot
hingestellt und es Gefäß für die notduft
ausgelehrt erst kurz vor seiner
Freilassung sei ein Mann bei ihm
erschienen habe ihn im Schreiben
unterrichtet und durch unablässige
Wiederholung beigebracht den Satz zu
sagen ein solcher Reiter möchte ich
werden der Kaspar Hauser hat übrigens
selbst behauptet dass er stehen und
gehen erst gelernt hat als der Mann ihn
schließlich nach Nürnberg bringt und vor
den Toren der Stadt absetzt also ist
auch total krass ein Mensch der ohne
Kontakt zu anderen aufwächst ohne
jeglichen Input und total isoliert ist
daher kommt übrigens auch der Begriff
Kaspar hauser-syndrom das deutet darauf
hin dass eine Person eine besonders
schwerwiegende Form der Vernachlässigung
erfahren hat bald zieht der rätselhafte
junge Mann eine unablässige Schar von
Besuchern aus ganz Europa an Ärzte
Juristen Theologen Lehrer alle Arten von
Wissenschaftlern oder Leute die sich
dafür halten versuchen sein Geheimnis zu
lüften Sie stellen Versuche mit ihm an
oder bemühen sich ihn zu erziehen unter
ihnen Paul Johan Anselm von Feuerbach er
gilt als einer der bedeutendsten
deutschen Rechtsgelehrten und Begründer
der modernen strafrechtslehre er
entwickelt ein besonders starkes
Interesse an dem Jungen und wird sein
Vormund die Frage woher kasparhauser
stammt lässt den Juristen nicht mehr los
aus seinen Gesprächen mit Casper und
verschiedenen Indizien entwickelt er
schließlich eine aufsehenerregende
Theorie Caspar Hauser so besagt sie sei
in Wirklichkeit der abprinz des Hauses
baden und damit legitimer Nachfolger des
Großherzogs Karl Friedrich
okay wow das ist ein Ding das müssen wir
jetzt erstmal noch ein bisschen weiter
aufdröseln das großherz zu tun Baden
wird zu dieser Zeit von Karl Ludwig
Friedrich von Baden regiert dieser ist
verheiratet mit Stefanie de boerné
pikanterweise eine Adoptivtochter
Napoleon bonaparts Karl Ludwig Friedrich
ist seinem Großvater Karl Friedrich von
Baden der im Jahr 1811 starb auf den
Thron gefolgt und okay okay lasst euch
nicht zu sehr von den Namen verwirren
die mochten uns damals offensichtlich
sehr kompliziert also Karl Ludwig
Friedrich Karl Friedrich warum konnte
man nicht einfach Holger oder Thorsten
heißen nur mal so zum Beispiel kleiner
Input meinerseits aber zum Glück sind
die Namen jetzt nicht so wichtig wichtig
ist der aktuelle großer Herzog das ist
der Enkel des vorherigen also sein Vater
ist vor seinem Opa gestorben so dass er
nie an die Reihe kam Luise Caroline von
Hochberg die zweite Ehefrau Karl
Friedrichs also des Opas um jetzt mal
beim Bild zu bleiben überlebte ihren
Mann sie hatte ihm Söhne geboren von
denen zwei das Kindesalter überlebten
diese waren jedoch von der Erbfolge
ausgeschlossen der Sohn aus erster Ehe
und dessen männliche Nachkommen sollten
die Linie des Hauses Baden weiterführen
Karl Friedrich hatte jedoch in seinem
Testament verfügt dass die Erbfolge auf
die Söhne Luise Carolines übergehen
sollten wenn die männliche Linie aus
seiner ersten Ehe ausstürme
Luise Carolines Wunsch ist natürlich
klar einer ihrer Söhne soll eines Tages
Großherzog von Baden werden
voraussetzung dafür ist dass der
regierende Karl Ludwig und seine Frau
ist Stefanie nur Töchter bekommen oder
dass ihre Söhne nie das Erwachsenenalter
erreichen
wie weit würde sie gehen um diesen
Wunsch zu erfüllen im Oktober 1812 wird
der erste Sohn von großherzoga Ludwig
und Stefanie geboren und stirbt kurz
nach der Geburt oder auch nicht aber der
Reihe nach die Kindersterblichkeit in
der Zeit ist damals sehr hoch also das
ein Kind nach der Geburt stirbt er regt
erstmal keinen Verdacht aber als der
16-Jährige Kaspar Hauser später
auftaucht betrachten einige die
Ereignisse im neuen Licht ihre Theorie
ist das Kind ist gar nicht gestorben das
Kind wurde auf geheißt von Luise
Caroline gingen anderes bereits tot
gewordenes Kind ausgetauscht das
eigentliche Kind wurde entführt und
gefangen gehalten eben Jena kasperhausen
diese Theorie findet zahlreiche Anhänger
sie ist ja auch sehr spektakulär denn
dadurch dass eine adoptiv Tochter
Napoleons involviert ist handelt es sich
sogar auch um eine internationale Affäre
die abprinzentheorie bekommt neue
Nahrung als am 29 mai 1833 Feuerbach
wichtigster Vertreter der abprinzen
Theorie Vormund und väterlicher Freund
von Caspar Hauser überraschend stirbt
man habe ihn vergiftet behauptet er auf
dem Sterbebett hat da jemand versucht
Spuren zu beseitigen schon vier Jahre
zuvor so scheint es hat es einen
geheimnisvollen Anschlag auf
kasparhauser selbst gegeben
Kaspar Hauser wohnt zu dieser Zeit im
Haus des Lehrers Georg Friedrich Daumer
am 17 Oktober 1829 so kasparhauser
selbst über die Tat greift ihn im Keller
des Hauses ein maskierter Mann mit einem
Messer an und droht du musst doch noch
sterben ehe du aus der Stadt Nürnberg
kommst
er erkennt die Stimme des Mannes es ist
derselbe der ihn gefangen gehalten und
schließlich von Nürnberg ausgesetzt hat
Kaspar Hauser kommt mit dem Schrecken
und einer blutenden aber harmlosen
stirnverletzung davon
doch wer immer ihm nach dem Leben
trachtet gibt nicht auf und mehr als
vier Jahre später hatte schließlich
Erfolg
am 14 dezember 1833 wird Kaspar Hauser
vermeintlich zur Besichtigung eines
Brunnens im Schlossgarten Ansbach
eingeladen als er dort eintrifft ist der
Hofgärtner der als Absender auf der
Einladung stand nirgends zu finden
Kasper Hauser ist allein als er sich
abwendet und zurückgehen möchte spricht
ihn ein bärtiger Mann an und reicht ihm
einen Beutel Casper greift nach dem
Beutel und der Mann sticht ihn ohne
Vorwarnung nieder
drei Tage später am 17 dezember 1833
gegen 22 Uhr stirbt Caspar Hauser an den
Folgen der Stichverletzung wer hat
kasparhauser ermordet wenn die
Erbprinzen Theorie stimmt liegt ein
Verdacht nach und zwar jemand wollte den
leiblichen Sohn von Karl Ludwig und
legitimen Erben des Großherzogtums Baden
ein für alle Mal beseitigen ja die
Vermutung liegt nah inzwischen nämlich
hat sich der Wunsch von Luise Caroline
erfüllt nachdem auch der zweite Sohn
Karl Ludwigs im Säuglingsalter gestorben
war ging die Erbfolge auf ihre Söhne
über seit 1830 regiert ihr Sohn Leopold
als Großherzog Karl Leopold der erste
Friedrich von Baden und seine
Regentschaft wäre unrechtmäßig wenn
Kasper Hauser wirklich der wäre für den
ihn manche halten neben der abprinzen
Theorie gibt es aber zahlreiche weitere
unter anderem wurde Kaspar Hauser für
den wiedergeborenen Jesus Christus
gehalten
schwierig ich glaube das können wir
ausschließen eine Theorie hat schon
damals genauso viele oder sogar mehr
Anhänger als die Geschichte vom
vertauschten Prinzen und zwar die
betrugstheorie diese besagt Caspar
Hauser war einfach nur ein Hochstapler
er ist niemals gefangen gehalten worden
hat sich alles ausgedacht ja das war
einfach nur eine große Story und ganz
sicher sei er kein erbfolger des
Großherzogs naja also einiges spricht
für diese Theorie vor allem der Zustand
des Jungen als er 1828 in Nürnberg
auftaucht ist es wirklich denkbar dass
ein Mensch sein ganzes Leben halbliegend
in einem stockfinsteren Raum verbringt
und sich nur von Wasser und Brot ernährt
und dann plötzlich auftaucht ohne
Zeichen von Mangelernährung oder anderen
körperlichen Schäden dass ein wenigen
Tagen laufen gelernt hat
heute wird das weitestgehend
ausgeschlossen und schon damals glauben
viele Zeitgenossen die Geschichte nicht
vermutlich hätte eine solche
Gefangenschaft niemand überlebt auf
keinen Fall jedoch ohne schwerste
psychische Schäden aufgrund der
Deprivation des reizenzzugs der
fehlenden sozialen Interaktion der
Mensch ist ein soziales Wesen und der
Kontakt zu anderen ist überlebenswichtig
doch aus welchem Grund sollte ein junger
Mann mit einer so fantastischen
Geschichte daherkommen naja stellt euch
vor ihr seid ein einsames Weisenkind im
19 Jahrhundert oder eure Eltern sind
arme Bauern Tagelöhner da gibt es keinen
anderen Ausweg keine andere Aussicht als
ein Leben in Armut und schwere Arbeit
außer die er findet ein anderes Leben
Kaspar Hauser wurde ja schließlich
umsorgt und versorgt er wurde
ausgebildet ja er verkehrt in den
höchsten Kreisen genießt ohne Ende
Aufmerksamkeit der wird ja damals fast
wie so ein Star behandelt und wenn er
aus einem Verhältnissen gestampft dann
hat ihm seine ausgedachte Geschichte
definitiven besseres Leben gesichert
aber was ist mit dem Mordversuch aus
1829 und dem Mord aus 1833 schon damals
sind viele Zeitzeugen überzeugt er hat
sich einfach selbst verletzt aber was
ist der mögliche Grund die
Aufmerksamkeit die ist geschwunden also
hat er den Entschluss gefasst sich
selbst zu verletzen und zack war wieder
zurück im Mittelpunkt das ging aber beim
zweiten Versuch deutlich daneben da dass
ich nämlich tödlich verletzt König
Ludwig der erste von Bayern setzt die
für damalige Verhältnisse unglaubliche
Summe von 10.000 Gulden Belohnung für
die Ergreifung des Täters aus ohne
Erfolg nach Abschluss der Untersuchung
1834 kommt das Kreis und Stadtgericht
Ansbach zu der Schlussfolgerung dass
erhebliche Zweifel gäbe ob ein Mord von
fremder Hand an Hauser verübt oder
überhaupt ein Verbrechen an ihm begangen
wurde und ein gewisser polizeiraten
Merker entscheidet auf selbstverwundung
ohne Tötungsabsicht der Tod Feuerbachs
der auf dem Sterbebett behauptete
vergiftet worden zu sein wird durchaus
plausibel als Folge eines Schlaganfalls
geschildert
letztlich geklärt ist der Fall
kasparhauser bis heute nicht aus
wissenschaftlicher Sicht scheint die
betrugstheorie viel plausibler doch die
Geschichte vom vertauschten Prinzen hat
noch immer viele Anhänger
1996 und 2001 wurden DNA-Untersuchungen
eingestellt unter anderem mit Blut von
der Hose die kasparhauser am Tag des
Mordes oder der selbstverwundung
getragen haben soll an der vermutlich
von ihm stammenden Haarlocke und an
seinem Hut man wollte herausfinden ob
Kaspar Hauser mit den lebenden
Nachkommen der großherzogins der Fanny
also der mutmaßlichen Mutter des
angeblichen Erben verwandt ist die
Ergebnisse von 1996 Schienen das
auszuschließen die spätere Untersuchung
brachte kurz zusammengefasst das
Ergebnis vielleicht vielleicht aber auch
nicht tja und da sind wir wieder da wo
wir waren die kriminalistische
Wunderwaffe DNA-Analyse kann einfach
nicht immer endgültige Gewissheit
bringen vor allem wenn das Verbrechen
fast 200 Jahre zurückliegt und niemand
ganz sicher sein kann welche Spuren und
Relikte 100% authentisch sind und die
ganze Zeit über unangetastet bleiben
vermutlich haben wir einfach mit der
Ungewissheit leben wer war Kaspar Hauser
wurde ermordet und wenn ja von wem und
warum es wurden viele Bücher darüber
geschrieben viele Filme gedreht viele
Gelehrte und weniger Gelehrte Schriften
darüber verfasst letztlich muss wohl
jeder selbst entscheiden was aus der
Geschichte macht auf alle Fälle ist es
eine Geschichte die wohl jeden von uns
fasziniert ich finde diese Geschichte
hat die Züge eines wenn auch grausamen
Märchens okay schon klar die meisten
historischen Märchen sind Teil sehr
grausam aber diese Geschichte bietet
Stoff für Anhänger von
Verschwörungstheorien
Kriminalgeschichten und Boulevard Themen
kurz um den Stoff für den großen
Blockbuster und natürlich würde man es
ihm Kaspar Hause gönnen nach Jahren des
Martyriums das als Kind in einem verließ
eingesperrt war und nun als Prinz
weiterleben könnte und damit so eine Art
Wiedergutmachung zu bekommen wie Märchen
halt dass die Geschichte mit einem Happy
End endet was aber leider hier nicht
gesch fest das Mysterium der Mythos
bleibt erhalten ich finde die Geschichte
zeigt auch wieder wie wichtig es ist
dass wir als Menschen die Community
brauchen verbrauchen Liebe wir brauchen
ein soziales Umfeld das ist damals wie
heute einfach unverändert gleichzeitig
zeigt die Geschichte aber auch was für
drastische Auswirkungen die
Vernachlässigung von Kindern haben kann
und deswegen bin ich froh dass es bei
uns mittlerweile etwas gibt wie
Jugendämter es ist nicht immer perfekt
aber immerhin gibt es Menschen die
hinschauen und an die wir uns wenden
können wenn uns etwas in unserem Umfeld
auffällt und damit sind wir am Ende der
heutigen Episode leider müssen wir euch
eine endgültige Klärung des Falls
schuldig bleiben daran haben sich schon
viele versucht und sind gescheitert eins
ist aber sicher Leben und Sterben von
Kaspar Hauser werden noch viele
Generation faszinieren und Stoff für
zahllose Geschichten liefern und
vielleicht taucht eines Tages doch noch
der alles entscheidende Hinweis auf
wir danken euch fürs zuhören und hoffen
dass ihr bei der nächsten Folge wieder
dabei seid bei Tatort Deutschland
Spezial euer Mirko und eure Natalie die
faszinierende Geschichte von Caspar
Hauser erzählen wir mit Schriften des
Kaspar Hauser forschungskreises am Karl
königinstitut sowie artikelauszügen aus
National Geographic Stern sowie dem
Artikel Kaspar Hauser der junge Mann der
aus dem Nichts kam aus der Süddeutschen
Zeitung aus dem Jahr 2019 Redaktion
Stefan Netzeband und Antonia Haier
Produktion Serverdienst